große Ereignisse werfen ihre Schatten
voraus diesmal ist es muratopal der
Comedian ist demnächst als Serienstar
basat 1 unterwegs in der Serie sie heißt
Spezialauftrag und das Besondere an ihm
übrigens bitte nicht wieder fragen wer
es ist in diesem Moment wo er dieses
Video seht sind hier links lauter Videos
mit muratopal zu sehen so funktioniert
YouTube und außerdem noch ein ganz
kleiner Tipp es gibt noch Google also
wir sind wieder bei morator der ist
Besondere an ihm ist nämlich er war
Polizist und dann wurde er Comedian noch
während seiner Polizei Karriere ist er
da umgestiegen und ähm hat sich ja eine
Menge aus diesem Spannungsfeld zu
erzählen und ich hoffe dass euch auch
eine Menge Fragen aus diesem
Spannungsfeld zwischen Staatsdienst und
lockeren Sketchen auf der Bühne
einfallen stellt also eure Fragen sie
sind wieder ziemlich gefragt und wenn
ihr Fragen zu den Fragen zu den Nutzer
Fragen habt dann guckt das FAQ das ist
hier hier da in so einer Anmerkung
verlinkt und liest den Info Text wir
sind gespannt ich glaube das habe ich
irgendwann schon mal gesagt